[Music]
DC Comics first of all I realize this is
probably not how you thought the story
would start
you mean with narration that's most
movies these days I think okay I'm all
for using animation to your advantage in
a fantasy world but this grappling hook
doesn't go anywhere near where she needs
it to go to get over this gap cartoon
cop is way better than most movie cops
because he actually shoots at the tires
but he's the same when it comes to aim
freakin a discount cursing the inside of
this truck is a Matrix Star Trek
holodeck background of greenish squares
also yes I know that is the netting
inside the truck bit but my question is
really this why does the truck need
netting all along each side of it just
what is this am i planning to haul a
bunch of Jack Jack's these asshats who
wastes tons of bullets firing on the
Batmobile must be thinking I've totally
got that magic bullet that's gonna
penetrate the fuck out of that
bulletproof glass just watch really I
admit the Batmobile is awesome and
everything but towing an armored truck
you can't just shoot a harpoon and
manipulate that thing willy-nilly it's
thousands of pounds after shooting it
Batgirl many times this guy decides
let's see if physics can take care of
this that girl doesn't get 75% skin burn
from this forced high-speed bailout no
foes now I'm no Killing Joke expert but
this movie seems very not Killing Joke
to me so far the strata can apparently
has tracking capabilities as if it's an
Ella copter or something they said they
could knock out the tracker on the
armored car I don't think they could
plug a computer in their ass I'm going
to assume that even the nerdiest of
computer nerds could not plug the
computer in their ass but it's possible
I'm not thinking fourth dimension dr.
Mann huh Barbara's friend tries to hook
her up with a man within the first few
seconds we see her out of costume
because you didn't know you were
watching How to Lose a Batman in ten
days
my dad's department has been setting up
city cams and reading a lot of 1984 but
I don't think that's related zoom and
enhance cliche also it's good to know
you can get to Gotham Street cams just
by going to the good ole each ttp
address oh great the eff out freaking
the eff out
this villain embodies all the classic
traits of villains with the compulsion
of sarcastic clapping can end the night
without a kiss is it about vanquishing
female foes that gets male villains all
date rapey
no seriously Batman stops off for coffee
at the Starbucks on the way to the crime
scene
what's that drive-thru conversation like
his name is Paris Paris Franz you're
kidding
just because you joke about it in movie
does not excuse this ridiculously
terrible character name and that's it
you speak in the words or law
god damn it Batgirl yes and this is not
a male/female thing it's a super
experience Batman super inexperience
Batgirl thing I thought you Brits like
the salt air that's racist they're
docked like close to town right does
this seem like a good spot to
assassinate someone in broad daylight
I can't they go with the let's take a
ride method where somebody's got a piece
of piano wire in the backseat these
monsters totally Wrath of Khan these
masked assailants look I know Gotham is
awful when it comes to crime but they
keep a truck involved in a crime in an
unguarded impound lot and just any
asshole can come strolling through here
and leave gifts first out of this Batman
movie is a Batgirl movie which is fine I
just wish they titled it correctly
you're getting hot hotter just out of
curiosity where did she put that still
transmitting foam also it's kind of
insulting that Batgirl is this freaking
stupid like the confidence part I'm
totally down with but the reckless part
surely she's better than this this guy's
talking openly about his crimes in a bar
I'm sure maybe he owns the bar but still
how come no bars near me you have sexy
art on the walls like this Batgirl black
widows herself out of a hairy situation
seriously an elevator is your exit
strategy she came in through a window
can't you go out that way Oh bull
Batgirl defeats Batman what the hell is
going on what the first off she wears a
bra under that second that top is that
easy to remove third how would you even
get aroused in the bat suit
not only is there limited room for
things to move around down there but
even touching bat girl's ass would be
like wearing rose gloves while caressing
the sign of a radial tire also did one
of you just happened to have a bat
condom on your belt because otherwise
bad pregnancy scare anyone
Demon's Boyer oh it was fantastic like
fireworks
thanks kitty purry on the left the
unnamed cafe utterly schools the
business to the right on signage here's
a small business tip don't put
hieroglyphs on your business name or
sign people need to be able to read that
Barbour gets ready to pay for her coffee
and holy cow expensive his coffee in
Gotham City
so do clingy feel trapped like I can't
move someone forgot to not draw or
animate this scene so it wouldn't be in
the movie we got a tip he might be
hiding out at the docks why the hell
would he tell her this if she's off the
case
Batman does not seem to understand that
Batgirl lives by her own rules we'll
talk later
animated Batman movie is much more sex
in the city than I think it intended to
be I just noticed Batgirl decided to
climb up and perch on top of this thing
which has to be the most uncomfortable
place in Gotham to be a disappointing
character whatever you assholes say
because he's Batman two questions like
how does he know this that or the other
thing I present you Batman being
completely unaware of his surroundings
and his Batmobile with all the gadgets
it has can't detect the missile headed
its way thirty minutes in still totally
about girl movie and still totally not a
Batman movie only 45 minutes left to
turn it around must be that time of the
month
I don't doubt this guy's an asshole and
might say something like this I just
thought since we're in 2016 and all we
were past these kinds of insults being
written into screenplays also I don't
envy you the beating that's coming after
you made that remark idiot meanwhile in
Gotham The Killing Joke hasn't started
yet Barbara has a perfect view of every
relationship in the city almost halfway
through this movie and still no Joker
mark hamill is probably as pissed about
this as Leno is about Suicide Squad I'll
find some way to fill my time well you
could start by actually working at the
library instead of filling your time
with gossiping and looking at street
cameras
Batgirl quits being Batgirl because
something something abyss something
reasons Corona came in gaping sea
eyeball says these poor saps died
probably three years ago after her
briefly eyeballing these corpses the
coroner came up with a pretty specific
timeline for when these assholes died
okay guys we need a sexy shot of a
cartoon woman so let's get out the horny
paint Batman casually parked his car on
the street and takes the long walk up
the driveway rather than keeping his
ride nearby and out of general view I
know right how in the fuck did the Joker
get another person into his cell make
him up to look like him in an escape
well it's garish ugly and smells like
this I guess the first 30 minutes of
this movie were just so we could see how
much Barbara means to Batman the second
act feels so disjointed from the first
act though it's like it doesn't belong
in the story began telling okay now that
this movie is two different stories
completely time for a flashback why stop
it - when you can get three picture of
the bet lady turns into a picture of a
pregnant woman and those things are not
the same Jesus whether any females
anywhere near the writing room for this
thing I have to go up on stage and
nobody laughs what made this guy want to
be a stand-up comedian any insight into
that is he a naturally funny guy and why
was he writing all of his hopes on
getting into show business I'm
completely sold right about now I'm
wondering why this guy who has an old
amusement park for sale decided to show
a potential buyer the place during the
middle of the night and didn't get
freaked out at a guy in clown makeup
showing up for the appointment
I guess he's never heard of the Joker
there girls on the street or not in a
weekend without having to tell a single
joke or blow a punch line Joker thinks
that these girls on the street aren't
spending their time blowing things I
love you job or no job you're good in
the sack and you make me laugh I tried
to get my wife to use these as her
custom wedding vows at our wedding but
she put the kibosh on that something
fierce still don't know why whenever
you're about to get into some hardcore
Joker research you need to hold up an
average Joker card and stare at it to
get in the mood this movie is
acknowledging a scene from Tim Burton's
Batman a movie incidentally that has a
completely different Joker origin story
except for the falling in acid part you
can't save everyone so especially gifs
you recently banked
what I mean you can't save everyone your
back I mean you can't save all the chick
off Barbara I swear you're fluffier than
your mother was weird that's the same
exact thing Batman said to her just
after coming on his own cape because she
suddenly wanted to keep hers clean what
that's the dirtiest joke I've ever told
well did you see the Kari video you did
damn that must be Colleen she's early
we're gonna work out why did Gordon
bring a scrapbook to Barbara's apartment
and why would Barbara invite him if she
knows Colleen is coming over to work out
he was just robbing banks then but the
headline specifically says the Joker is
a murderer and a homicidal maniac
Joker shoots Barbara right in the uterus
for some reason Jesus do these sweaters
just fucking hate women also man this
bullet has unbelievable propulsive
powers in fact the idea for walking
anywhere seems remote our venue wasn't
built with the disabled
and joker seems to know that his gut
shot cause Batgirl paralysis even though
science itself won't know this for hours
okay given the technology featured in
this movie we can assume the present-day
is someone around 2016 if the Joker's in
his 50s then he'd have been of marrying
age around the late 80s or early 90s
definitely not a time when old-time
sailors were hanging out at bars like
they're about to be shipped out to fight
the Third Reich there's nothing really
wrong with anything the future Joker is
saying here I just need to point out
that the guy in a background is perhaps
the stillest motherfucker I have ever
seen just a moment ago these crooks
snapped at future Joker for not being
cool when talking about the robbery he's
helping them with now they open up an
incriminating bag and painting a red
hood that everyone's seen in the papers
in front of everybody
can't make a nest without breaking a few
eggs yeah that's funny
no it's cliche no it's neither of those
she'll never walk again doctor says this
after performing the most rudimentary
neurological test possible also few do
did you not see Forrest Gump dirty
rotten scoundrels the way he was faking
in that movie also if she were Batman
they'd find a way to get her back to
health in at least three months she
found the victim in a state of undress
is the movie implying that in addition
to being shot and paralyzed Barbara
Gordon was also raped because that is
some heavy-ass for a Batman story let
alone a goddamn cartoon the implication
alone is sin worthy god damn how much
does this movie hate Batgirl
now hang the phone right there you're
telling me Joker had enough time to get
the lights on repair a lot of the
equipment decorate the park plant a
million TVs in the ghost train shoot
Barbara Gordon and build a throne on a
pile of creepy baby dolls
remember reason what our reason is based
on if we deny them we deny reason itself
Joker expounds this freshman-year
philosophy to a naked man in a roller
coaster who's surrounded by little
people there is no sanity clause kids
man hate to break it to you but Joker
just spoiled the fact that there's no
sanity clause it's just your dad 'no
suit wear a suit and a bowtie it's kind
of the trademark with this red hood
business henchman says this to a person
that is already wearing a suit and
bowtie that was an accident this morning
just seen a baby bottle heater the story
actually takes away any motivation that
this guy would have to help this gang
but they're going to make him do it
anyway which is poignant i guess the way
things are some sort of moral lesson
learned i don't know all these
underground casino thugs attacked with
nothing but this i don't know about you
but if i were opening my own underground
casino I'd hire thugs that carry guns
for
gun stop Batman fists do not holy grant
these are the hottest this side of town
hookers I've ever seen I don't have any
doubt that the Joker came up with this
song while he was in the asylum he's had
plenty of time to do that but what I
don't think he's had time to do is get
all of his carny folk properly
choreographed for this number then
there's a certain thing I do
this goes on for some time amazing how
tasteful these photographs are of
Gordon's naked paralyzed daughter Joker
was also able to take digitized and
upload to this ride multiple pictures of
a wounded Barbara well I gave the
breathe my voice sounds actly
if the hood is that tight there's no way
his voice would sound echo II said there
was no security
they must have altered things since I
left yeah but why was there a rash of
chemical robbery since he left as far as
the unluckiest person I've ever seen
during an origin story that man
apparently abandons pursuit as soon as
Joker Falls after scare tripping him
don't worry guys he just landed in the
chemicals that changed your entire
appearance and make you go mad but they
aren't fatal rather than go right or
left around this dead guy Batman decides
to get out of the car and walk down the
completely open Midway isn't this the
fucking Dark Knight who always got the
drop on criminals by being one step
ahead how did the Joker convince all the
freaks of the already close carnival to
fight for him against Batman no worry
guys Batman's got a Binaca spray that
helps him treat wounds from Joker's acid
never leave home without it I feel my
point old engine man so Joker's whole
plan was to drive Commissioner Gordon
mad feels like he could have come up
with a better plan than this and one
that didn't require buying an old
amusement park you had a bad day once on
my ride - oh god please don't show
Bruce's parents getting murdered again
please don't joke Bruce's parents
getting murdered again please don't show
booths problem with a surprise trapdoor
is once you start falling you shouldn't
be able to reach the ledge but he's
Batman Joker takes out Batman with a
fucking lobster pot and I'm all done
with this movies Joker he's as sane as
he ever was
I wonder if this plan to make Gordon
insane would have worked if he had just
killed Barbara instead of paralyzing her
I mean Joker gave Gordon and out in this
plan to make him think she was dead when
she really wasn't
that's a gift in this twisted world how
would this gun which shot real bullets
be able to shoot a joke sign once it was
out of bullets
but the second guy said what do you
think I am crazy you just turn it off
when I'm halfway across it takes an hour
and 11 minutes for this joke to kill or
whatever it is jokes - so what happened
did Batman kill the Joker did he put him
back in the asylum where he can
apparently escape it will whatever the
answer is simple it why would that joke
change
that man's mind about killing him why
would he trust Arkham to keep
entertained there's no good answer tell
us what to thank for God's sake oh wait
there's more this is part of the story
that could only be told after a full
minute of credits that's frightened me
[Music]
instead I want his family dead I want
his house burnt to the ground I want to
go to the middle not even a Brazil Jack
mistletoe can be deadly if you eat it
mmm but a kiss can be then deadly or if
you mean it he's taking it to the limit
this time
[Music]
this length of our primary
communications antenna broke off and
tore through my bio monitor and ripped a
hole in me as well but the the antenna
and and the blood really managed to seal
the breach in my suit good where'd you
go psycho boy
I felt like destroying something
beautiful I'm sorry it's just that
don't forget I'm also just a girl
standing in front of a boy asking him to
love her oh god oh god it's okay
let it come uh phrasing in a comic you
know how you can tell who the Arts
villains going to be he's the exact
opposite of the hero and most times
they're friends like you and me
[Music]